SEMYON VARLAMOV.
HE IS PLAYING IN HIS TENTH ROAD
GAME THIS SEASON AND BY
VARLAMOV..
>> Daryl: A WILD SHIFT
RICK BOWNESS WAS ASKED ABOUT
THIS UPCOMING SCHEDULEENDER
INTERFERENCE PRIOR TO THE
1-1.
>> Daryl: NOA13-GAME GOAL DROUG
HEADED INTO
THE STARS WITH NO WITH PELECH.
TROTZ' CLUB THIS THE FINAL TIME
SEE BIG Z WHO HAD A BEEN ALIVE G
AS CHARA HAS BEEN AN NHLER.R. S.
THE STARS BROKE.
THE GUY THAT MAKES IT HAPPEN
HEISKANEN WILL WRIST IT TO MINU
PERIOD.
HERE IS NELSON. HE
PULOCK THEIR
SKATING LEGS AND CAME CLOSE TO
MAKING IT A 4- THE
STARS POURED IN OVER TO CENTER..
OVER TO SEGUIN. VARLAMOV MADE
THE SAVE.
HETO GET IT AWAY FROM THEHE FRO
HIM. MATT
BARZAL.
>> Daryl: IT IS A SPECIAL